Sunday night Miranda Lambert took home
her seventh straight a female vocalist
of the Year award at the Academy of
Country Music Awards I'm really excited
for women in country music and I'm glad
to be here as one of them only et was
with her backstage congratulations now
what lucky number seven
female artist of the year number seven
yeah I can't really grasp that but I'm
so thankful I've been writing a ton and
I'm just I'm never gonna stop what are
you writing about what can we expect oh
I got tons I got tons I'm just like I've
luckily have to put off the road a
little bit so I've been able to kind of
go into the creative mode when you go
through a bunch of stuff and you got it
more to write about yeah absolutely it's
really been a great summer for me and
winner just like I started Brighton in
the summer and just you know getting
creative that's what I do that's what I
love the most you arrived in your
beautiful yellow dress you look so happy
do you thing like like things are very
happy for you well thank you I was I am
happy and yellows a happy color
I hardly ever wear yellow but it so it
hasn't rock and roll to it did you ever
think you would be 7 times female
vocalist of the year absolutely not I
was hoping for like one bit but I'm I'm
thankful and all it does is make me want
to work harder honestly